WILLIAM LI: This
year, we had a number
of students who had taken
the class before who
we are interested in
being involved in some way
and acting as
mentors for projects.
And so what happened was every
week in our Wednesday afternoon
labs, the teams of students
would meet with their mentor,
and give them an update,
and get feedback from them
on their project progress.
[? I ?] think the one core
reason of doing this this year
was to really draw on the
experiences of our mentors,
having gone through the entire
process in a previous semester
and also being very passionate
about assistive technology
and passionate about how we
go about teaching this class,
and also to try to keep teams
on track, to really understand
the different milestones,
the different deadlines
and iterations that are
important to be able to deliver
a successful project,
a successful prototype
by the end of the course.
I think overall it was
successful in terms
of having that personal
interaction with somebody
with some experience to guide
teams along in the process.